all right so this is our continuing Jo
strike and practice series know exactly
what to call but basically instead of
the emphasis being on you know going
through all these forms let's understand
why the things we have an Aikido exists
right so why do the different kinds of
practices we have exist in the first
place so let's look at the top they
series so this is a three-strike series
in the middle of sight the sensei's
savuti consists of top 10 getting guys
get that they pull mooch and thought
that hot chino g-guys so what are they
doing so I can I could spend a video
talking about the details of these
things but more important thing is to
understand grossly why these exist and I
think most Aikido practitioners were
including weapons don't have an idea as
to why these exist
generally the quítate series exists for
one of two reasons either one I've lost
control of my weapon or two I'm trying
to get a longer strike than I normally
would have been able to get right so for
example you know Josh and I were here
and I was in a a regular Ken come I or
something like this and Joshua was just
short of being able to be hit if I scoot
this out to a one-handed strike you can
see now that I'm easily able to hit him
right so by using one hand they get more
reach than I would normally get also
could be that my hand the weapon got
knocked free in my hand and how can I
reset that so that I could use it again
and this is a lot of what we're seeing
in this series we're gonna look at the
gaming guys trying to have a really nice
partner savuti that I think explains a
lot about this and kind of also explains
x-mas which directions with me here for
this also really does a nice job of
showing how we can be deceptive with our
Suba action so Suba is this action the
sliding action so if Josh and I were
here and I could step in and thrust him
right so he's in distance right now I
could successfully step in and get him
and josh has answered this was simply
the step back okay now we know that
every time I attack Josh can just step
back one out of range right so he's got
an idea of my distancing now of course I
can hop in further but he could also hop
out further so at this distancing every
time I chased this guy down he's gonna
be able to successfully get away from me
I can set him up with that though by
using a
they and trick him so I can use to talk
they getting ice in this so as I come in
he gets back I used my su bet he sees
the prepping for the ski when I deliver
the ski I'll miss cuz he's gone back now
the next time I do it when I sue bet
instead of bringing the hand up for a
ski I'm gonna slide my back hand in so
instead of delivering this way I'm gonna
slide my back hand in and now when he
goes to step back as I come through you
can see I'll get a really long strike
and I do this in two ways one I'm using
NAU meows you step inside the sukiyaki
so suggestions are shorter meaning if I
just keep going like this I'm never
gonna get this guy however if I take an
au me a sheet it'll be useful
plus I'm using the Jo in the longest way
possible so as I set up here for my
second shot this comes here he can go
back really far and I'm still gonna be
able to clip him here with the getting
guys so I'm changing my submit action
from being delivering a ski to
delivering this is getting guys it's a
really nice deceptive action works
really good if someone's just trying to
get out get out get out get out now I
use the weapon in a different way and I
get a long reach all of a sudden there's
a lot of times how we might use tommooch
let's say if we got a partner who's
working in Ken come on and he's
attacking me a lot and I'm just using
bonds you know combined for defense so
as he's coming in you know this is
happening a lot okay now key words stand
there I could maybe follow up with the C
or something bang bang and get in here
but what if every time he hits me he's
hopping back so fast he gets out of
there and so I'm trying to get him and
it's not working for me not working for
me so he can take advantage of the fact
that I'm in a shortcoming he's a lunk
mind you know in and out of distance but
if I use Tomo hooch from this I can
suddenly change the distance in so if
you were to hop in and hop out as I come
through with my toe mode you can see now
I get a really long strike on that right
isn't even longer strike that I would
get if I went to kiddin come I also so
of course he comes in and hops out I
could go to Ken come on and maybe get
him see just a little short there but if
I use the toe Malucci pops in puff you
can see how in the queue
stri where I can really come in and clip
him so by using that top a series like
that I'm getting a lot of reach a lot of
reach which is really nice for me I
could also be having to use my weapon in
such a fast manner that are not able to
successfully defend what's going on
right so so if he knocks it free from my
hand and what am I going to do so we
were in some kind of position and Josh
for maybe to use like a coal barrage for
example and knocked the weapon over my
hand in this position it's not really
too much I can do I need to get my hand
back to my weapon but while I'm doing
that maybe he's attacking me all kinds
of bad stuff happening right but if I
were to use something like hot you know
you guys better I need to come in here I
can immediately give him working right
so even if I don't hit him I get him to
back up off of me here so that way he's
away from me and the hot you know you
guys shouldn't set me up in that kind of
position there's lots of things we can
work with with this I could use a
changing of range in the same way so
let's say Jobs was in a Khimki mine and
I'm in a joke of mine now I'm in a
serious disadvantage she's got a nice
long reach when he comes in for me I hop
back out of range and now I immediately
have a long ranging weapon to come in
and hit him with so because I switched
this here now I step in I have a huge
roots that I can come back at this guy
so instead of having to be forced back
back back back back
I can switch to this Hut you know g-gosh
action in order to make this work for me
right so as he comes in for me I can hop
back out of this range and then come in
with a nice long reach to get him so the
top day series useful for if I only have
one hand on the weapon how can I make it
function or if I need to make a long
reaching action how can I do that
this is the Kitab a series